well tonight teachers are furious and
frustrated with their health insurance
for not paying up many plan to attend a
rally tomorrow to demand health care
funding tht health covers around 18
thousand teachers and their dependents
oracle mana shares concerns from
teachers and what changes are already
being made
the crux of the issue is the amount of
money thc health is getting is less than
the amount of money needed to pay out an
increase in medical claims the company
says there are more claims as a result
of the pandemic but teachers tell us
they just want their bills paid in the
last week i've gotten
several claims in the mail that have not
been paid ccsd teacher rebecca kershall
is dealing with the health care headache
she says tht health is not taking care
of her medical bills and when she called
them she got this response there are
thousands
thousands of teacher claims that have
been denied you're just going to have to
be patient don't tell me just be patient
i need more than that now she's taking
action she'll join teachers at a rally
outside of thursday's ccsd school board
meeting to demand health care funding it
shouldn't have to come to this point to
make change but it often does t-h-t
health hired a new ceo has designed new
health plans and is changing its
governing board the teachers union lists
other upgrades being made but teachers
like kendall pornis who saddled with an
unpaid surgery bill of fifteen thousand
dollars isn't too confident i think
it'll it will just kind of put a lid on
the problems for now what we really care
about is are you going to pay the bills
we don't want this going to collections
in may ccsd gave tht health an advance
of 35 million dollars but the teachers
union wants the district to do more with
existing budget issues pornis has her
doubts where is that money going to come
from even with the changes kerschel
wants proof of the progress it's lovely
to make promises right i'd like to see
action i reached out to the teachers
union but they told me no one was
available to speak with me and i did not
hear back from tht health reporting in
las vegas orco mana 8 news now